foreign
welcome back to another video session by
simply learn in this session on C plus
plus full course for beginners we will
be learning different concepts and
topics of C plus plus
this video tutorial will help you in
learning and understanding the C plus
programming language in both theoretical
and practical way by doing some Hands-On
examples
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so we'll start with the introduction to
C plus plus programming language and how
to download and install C plus plus in
Windows then we will start with the
force programming C plus plus along with
the terms like variables types then the
concepts like if else statements Loops
functions in C plus plus call by value
call by reference and friend function
then we will cover topics like arrays
pointers in C plus plus this pointer
references and memory management we will
also learn about sorting in C plus plus
after that we will move on to object
oriented programming topics like classes
in C plus plus oops Concepts Etc and
after that we will move on to topics
like vectors in C plus plus STL that is
standard template library and in the end
we'll also learn to make some projects
in C plus
so without further Ado let's get started
so let's start with the introduction to
C plus plus programming
C plus plus is a popular programming
language introduced by John strowstrup
in the year 1979. the aim was to make a
dynamic language that is efficient and
has some additional features to see
initially it was called C with classes
as it was an extension to C language but
later renamed as C plus plus
it is general purpose case sensitive
language and it is called pre-compiled
language because it converts the source
code directly to the machine
understandable code
it is an intermediate level language
because it contains both features of
high level and low level language
C plus plus supports the features of
object oriented language like
encapsulation inheritance polymorphism
Etc it also supports procedural
programming and functional programming
as well
welcome to this video where we'll be
telling you how you can install C plus
on vs code and Dev C plus plus after we
are done with the installation we'll
also learn how to run a program on both
of these code editors so we'll start
with Visual Studio code
to download vs code let's go to Google
and search for visual studio code
or vs code
we'll click on this first link
this is the official webpage for
downloading the visual studio code
and we'll now click on this download for
Windows Blue Button
and now we'll click on download now
here it is getting download and
as you can see
thanks for downloading Visual Studio
code for Windows
once we are done with the download we
can click on this open folder
here it is
now we need to install this file so
we'll double click on this file
and this is a set of wizard
we'll click on this I accept the
agreement
and we'll click on next
as we have accepted the license
agreement now we can select our
destination folder or we can leave it as
it is but make sure there must be 293.2
MB of free space on that particular disk
space
now
we'll click on next
here we can again click on X there is no
need to change over here
and now
you can click on this create a desktop
icon button or anyone else as for your
choice
now we'll click on next
and now we'll click finally on install
it is getting installed it will take
some time
now we can click on this finish button
launch Visual Studio we have marked it
it is already marked so when we click on
this finish button it will launch the
visual studio code
so as we can see this is the visual
studio code
so as we have installed vs code now we
have to configure it so that the C plus
plus programs can run in this code
editor
so in order to do that we need to add
some extensions so we'll click on this
extensions button
now here we will write code Runner
extension we'll write code Runner
and this is extension
when click on this install
and it is getting installed
here are some instructions we can click
on Control Plus alt plus n or press F1
and then select type run code but we'll
deal with that later
now
we'll add another extension that is C
slash C plus plus
here it is
we'll click on this install
here we can see downloading Visual
Studio Windows debugger
it is getting installed and I think it
is installed now
so as we have added both the extensions
so let's move on and do a program of C
plus plus in this code editor
we can Define strings as a collection or
group of characters
it is basically used to represent text
in the program and we can perform many
operations on strings in order to
manipulate it
the syntax of string contains a
collection of characters surrounded by
double quotes for example here string is
the type Str is the name of the string
and coffee is the value that is assigned
to the string
in C plus plus there are two ways to
create a string
first is C style strings in C style
strings collection of characters are
stored in the form of arrays they are
basically arrays of type character
the second way is using string objects
we can create string object to hold a
string
they are implemented in the standard
Library which we must include in the
program using hash include
so here we will do an example of string
and we'll do some push back and pull
back operation on it so first of all
we'll include the header file
hash include iostream
then using namespace standard
namespace standard okay now we'll start
with int Main
all right first of all we'll write
string
data type then the name of the string s
here s is the name of the string all
right now first of all we will display a
message
to enter a string
so
okay enter a string
no
get line
this is the syntax when you want to take
the input
of a string so get line C in is used to
take the input and S is the name of the
string
so this is how we take the input
and now we will print another message
saying that
you have entered
now here we will print the string s
next line and
okay
now
we'll do some operations like s dot
pushback
this will add an element at the end of
the string
so
let's say we want to add y
so we'll write y inside the bracket
s dot pushback and inside the bracket
with single quotes we'll write y
now
will display a message saying
after
thank you
after using
pushback function
will print the string
that is after using the function
pushback the string would look like this
and
now
we'll use another function s dot pop
back
it will delete the element from the end
so we'll write C out
and we'll display the message
after using PowerBack function
let's write pop back only
and we'll print the
string
okay now after that we'll write return
0.
and I think it's done only the spelling
is wrong over here
okay
yeah now let's try to run this
as you can see the message enter a
string so let's say I have entered
Barcelona
so you have entered Barcelona after
using pushback Barcelona why because we
have used y over here we want to add y
at the end of the string so after using
pushback Barcelona Y and pop back
function after that we have used and we
know that it will delete the element
from the end so
here we can see there is no y pop back
function have deleted the element
so this is our output
next is if else statements
if else are two conditional statements
that are generally used when we want to
run the code based on some conditions
we run a block of code which is inside
if statement only if the condition is
true for example
if the number variable here is equal to
10 then only the block of code will
execute and will print the message you
got it
otherwise it will run the else block and
display the message written inside that
block which is not this one so first of
all we'll create a new file we'll go to
file and click on this new file
now in order to save this one we can
click on control s or we can go over
here and click on this save as
now we can select the location
like
let's keep it over here only
let's name it as
visual dot CPP dot CPP is extension
which is used when we want to do a
program in C plus plus
now I will click on this save button
now let's do a simple program to check
whether the program is running on this
code editor or not
so we'll include the header files
include IO stream
now we'll write namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now inside end main will display a
message
welcome to this video
okay now return zero
make sure to
save this after making changes or you
can click on Ctrl s or you can go to
file
and click on this save
so once you have saved the program now
you can run it
we can click on this play button it will
run the code
as we can see in the output
welcome to this video we can see
here it is
so it means our program is working it is
running fine now let's do another
example in which we will take the inputs
from the user
so let's make a new file
we'll go to file and click on this new
file
now we will save as
and we'll write visual
2 dot CPP
all right in this program we'll take the
input from the user
so start with
header files hash include iostream
our spelling is wrong
hash include iostream after that using
namespace standard
now inside int Main
we'll take the inputs from the user
will display the message
enter the
first number
Now using C in
we'll take the input
we forgot to mention this declare this
N1 variable so write int N1
and and two
and it
sum equals 0.
all right here we have taken the input
of N1 the first number now we'll take
the input of another number by
displaying the message
enter the second number
we'll write N2
now we'll
add both of these
and 1 plus
N2
and will display the result
we'll write end line
so that it looks good
all right now we need to save it
we'll go to file I'll click on this save
now it is saved now we can run this
program
we'll click on this run code
now in order to write the first number
over here that is in order to write in
the terminal we have to configure the
visual studio code and to do that then
open it again
once you are done
now
let's try to run this
so now you will be able to write the
inputs
like let's say
the first number is 4
now the second number let's say
9.
on addition it becomes 13 which is the
right answer
so these were some configurations that
you need to do if you want to run a
program of C plus plus in Visual Studio
code
so as we have understood how to download
and configure Visual Studio code for C
plus programs so let's move on to learn
how we can download Dev C plus plus and
run C plus plus programs in that
so let's go to Google
and type Dev C plus plus
this is the first link
we'll click on that now this is the
green button saying download will click
on that to download Dev C plus plus
as you can see it is getting downloaded
your download will start shortly
so now we'll click on download now
it is getting downloaded
it will take a while the size of this
file is 48.1 MB
so as you can see the downloading is
almost done
so the downloading is complete now we'll
click on open folder
here it is Dev C plus plus setup
now we'll click on this setup
we'll click on yes
the setup is loading
so now here we will select the preferred
language it is English we'll click on OK
now we'll click on this is the license
agreement we'll click on I agree
now
we'll click on next we don't need to
change this I think the space required
is 346.8 MB
and we'll click on next
now if you want to change the
destination folder you can but I don't
want to change it so I'll click on
install
now it is getting installed it will take
a while
it's done and now we'll click on finish
and it is marked so when we click on
finish it will launch the dev C plus
plus
so here we have to select the language
it is English so we'll click on next
here again we'll click on next and now
we'll click on OK
so this is our code editor that is Dev C
plus plus
so let's write a code
first of all let's create a file
we'll go to file and go to new and we
click on source file
all right now we need to save this one
and in order to save this we'll click on
file then we'll go to save as
and now we'll select the destination
and name it as
Dev dot CPP
all right now let's start
with the header file
hash include IO stream
we'll do a simple program over here
using namespace
STD
because we want to check that whether
the program is running in this editor or
not
namespace STD
now we'll write int Main
inside into main will display a message
welcome
to
Dev C plus plus
all right after that we'll write return
0.
now let's try to run this and in order
to run this program we'll go to execute
and now we'll click on compile and run
here this is the pop-up welcome to Dev C
plus plus as we can see this is the
output now press any key to continue it
will close this window
so our output is correct welcome to Dev
C plus plus so this is how you can run a
program in Dev C plus plus
and
our program was also working fine in the
visual studio code
so this is how you can download both of
these code editors to run the C plus
programs today we'll be discussing about
loops in C plus plus so let's begin and
see what's in it for you
so we are going to be learning today
about while Loops what is a loop then
different types of Loops like for Loop
while loop do while loop then there is
nested Loop after that there are control
flow statements like break and continue
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the Subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting Tech videos
so let's start with the first topic that
is while loops
in order to perform a particular task or
operation many number of times we need
loops these are used when we want to
execute a block of statement repeatedly
rather than just writing those
statements again and again
for example imagine you want to display
your name on the screen 50 times now to
do that there are two methods method one
is writing your name 50 times by doing
the hard code
and Method 2 is writing your name once
with a loop condition and your name will
be automatically displayed 50 times
now it is pretty obvious that you would
prefer the second approach because you
don't have to put effort in writing your
name 50 times plus it is easy to write
code in few lines
so method 2 is the functionality of loop
it reduces time in writing the code plus
it increases the simplicity
now let's understand what is a loop
Loops in computer programming is a
series of tasks that are used to run
some particular code repeatedly until a
specific condition is met
Loops tells the computer when to start
the condition and when to stop it
now this is a basic flow of a loop after
the initialization the condition is
checked if it's true then the blog of
statement will get executed as long as
the condition is true and if the
condition is false the loop will
terminate
depending on the program different types
of Loops are used in different times
so let's first see different types of
loops
first is for Loop then while loop then
there is do while loop after that there
is nested Loop these are four types of
Loops in C plus plus so let's discuss
these loops
first is for Loop it is a repetition
control structure that is used to
iterate a piece of code based on the
condition is true or false if the
condition is true the statement inside
the loop body is executed and once if it
returns Falls the execution of statement
will get terminated and after every
execution of for Loop the incremental
decrement paths will update the loop
counter
now let's move on to the while loop
in this Loop the condition is evaluated
first of instructions inside the loop
body will execute and this will happen
repeatedly until the condition becomes
false and when it becomes false the loop
will end
now the main difference is we use for
Loops when we know the number of time
this little or that it will repeat the
loop as long as the condition is true
that means in do while blue body will
execute at least once irrespective of
the test condition
now coming to the nested Loop
when one Loop is defined inside the body
of another loop then it is known as
nested Loop in C plus plus there are at
least 256 levels of nesting and the flow
of execution for nested Lopez First it
includes initialization of variable
followed by condition 1 if it gets
satisfied then it will search for the
second condition if that also gets
satisfied then it will get increment and
when the condition gets satisfied it
will search for the new set of
statements and follows the same flow of
execution
in C plus plus break statements are used
to terminate the execution of the loop